Einfach entspannt auf der eigenen
Terrasse eine rauchen?
Für Dirk Dowe in Dortmund ist
das nicht mehr möglich.
Schon wieder kurz vor 12 - jetzt aber
mal schnell die letzten Züge,
sonst droht der Knast!
Das Dortmunder Landgericht hat Herrn
Dowe nebst Gattin dazu verurteilt,
im heimischen Garten nur
nach Stundenplan zu rauchen.
Tabakkonsum ist seither nur
noch im Dreistundentakt legal,
ansonsten strengstens verboten.
Immer von 12 bis 3 nicht,
von 3 bis 6 wieder ja
und von 6 bis 9 wieder nicht,
von 9 bis 12 ja.
Und das auch halt im
24-Stunden-Rhythmus.
Nachts!
Nachts. Ich dürfte nachts
um drei aufstehen,
dürfte mir 'nen Wecker stellen,
hier hinsetzen,
bis sechs Uhr hier sitzen und rauchen.
Der Rauch stört die Nachbarn, aber
erst seitdem die Dowes
ein Dach über ihrer
Terrasse installiert haben.
Ein wundersames Dach, das den
Qualm auf magische Weise umleitet.
Und der Rauch soll von hier
aus rüberziehen, wie 'n Kamin wirken
und über den Zaun rüber,
runter auf die - deren Terrasse,
die ein Stückchen tiefer liegt und
dann bei denen in(s) Haus rein
beziehungsweise auch in 'n Keller
oder ins Schlafzimmerfenster.
Seit drei Jahren beschäftigen Dowes Dach
und dessen Rauchströmungen die Gerichte.
Während das Amtsgericht keine
Belästigung der Nachbarn feststellte,
urteilte das Landgericht: 'Ja, es stinkt'
- und verordnete den
strafbewehrten Rauchplan.
Seither drohen den Dowes Geldstrafen
von bis zu 250.000 Euro
oder gar sechs Monate Gefängnis
für außerplanmäßiges Qualmen
in der eigenen Gartenidylle.
Und hier ganz hinten im Garten?
Darf ich auch nicht rauchen.
Hier dürfen Sie nicht rauchen?
Nein, im Garten nicht, im ganzen
hinteren Bereich nicht.
Warum?
Weil es der Richter so festgelegt hat und
die Nachbarn (das) so gefordert haben.
Die Nachbarn wollen übrigens
vor der Kamera nicht
über den Zigaretten-Kleinkrieg reden.
In Dortmund ist der Streit Stadtgespräch –
unter Rauchern und Nichtrauchern:
Da frag ich mich, warum die überhaupt
rauchen. Das ist doch gesundheitsschädlich.
Das weiß man doch.
Eigentlich sollte man sich einfach
mal um sich selbst kümmern,
weil mit Sicherheit gibt’s im
Nachbarhaushalt auch irgendwas,
was diejenigen stört und
da wird nichts gesagt.
Und nur weil's ums Rauchen geht,
heißt es dann:
Ne, soll man nicht mehr tun,
und deswegen dann 'nen
Gerichtsstreit anfangen - weiß ich nicht.
Das ist wirklich sehr deutsch, also
dass man alles so eingrenzt
und ab dann darf man keinen
Krach machen zu Hause,
ab dann soll man rauchen: Das ist
schon 'n bisschen Privatsphäre.
Qualm hin, Qualm her –
der Rechtsanwalt der Dowes
kann die Argumentation
der Richter nicht nachvollziehen.
Hier werden zwei Grundrechtspositionen
ja auch - um die wird gestritten.
Einmal das gesundheitliche Recht,
was die Nachbarn behaupten,
sie wären beeinträchtigt, und das Recht
der Eheleute Dowe auf ihrem Grundstück,
auf ihrem Eigentum, ist ja nicht Miete,
ist Eigentum, zu machen grundsätzlich,
was sie wollen, auch zu rauchen.
Die Nachbarn vertreten wohl die
Meinung vieler Deutscher,
denn Nichtrauchen liegt im Trend.
So mancher fordert noch
stärkeren Nichtraucherschutz.
Dabei wird schon jetzt restriktiv
mit Rauchern umgegangen:
in Kneipen, Büros und Flughäfen drängen
sie sich in den ausgewiesenen Zonen.
Das Rauchen im
Privatbereich bleibt strittig.
So, wie spät haben wir's?
4 Minuten vor 12.
Das heißt in vier Minuten…
...darf ich hier nicht mehr rauchen.
Aber ich?
Ja klar, sie dürften jetzt ihre
ganzen Kollegen mitbringen,
die dürften jetzt alle rauchen.
Denn Schlag zwölf beginnt
zwar das Rauchverbot
- aber nur für die Dowes heißt es:
Zigarette aus.
Logisch ist das nicht, aber laut
Richterspruch darf sich hier jedweder Gast
rund um die Uhr die Lunge
aus dem Halse qualmen.
Auch der Reporter, und Herr
Dowe guckt zu.
Nach 12! Kein Problem!
In Dortmund ist Qualm und Qualm
eben längst nicht dasselbe.